what do we know
about
from that book and the research beyond
uh about race differences
and intelligence it's still the most
incendiary topic in psychology nothing
has changed that
anybody who even discusses it is easily
called a racist just for discussing it
it's become fashionable to find racism
in
any discussion
like this
it's unfortunate
the short answer to your question is
there's been very little actual research
on this topic
since 19
since the book of
since the bell curve even before
this really became incendiary in 1969
with an article published by an
educational psychologist named arthur
jensen
let's just take a minute and go back to
that
to see the bell curve in a little bit
more historical perspective
arthur jensen was a educational
psychologist at uc berkeley i knew him
as well
and um
in 1969 or 68 the harvard educational
review
asked him
to
take an uh to do a review article on the
early childhood education programs that
were designed to raise the iqs
of minority
students
this was before the federally funded
head start program head start had not
really gotten underway at the time
jensen undertook his review
of what were a number of demonstration
programs
and these demonstration programs
were
for young children around kindergarten
age and they were specially designed to
be cognitively stimulating to provide
lunches
do all the the things that people
thought would
uh minimize this this average gap of
intelligence tests there was a a strong
belief
among virtually all psychologists
that the cause of the gap was unequal
opportunity due to racism due to all you
know all negative things in the society
and if you could
compensate for this the gap would go
away so early childhood education back
then was called literally compensatory
education
jensen looked at these programs he was
an empirical guy he understood
psychometrics
and he wrote a it was over a hundred
page article detailing
these programs and the flaws in their
research design
some of the programs reported iq gains
of on average five points but a few
reported 10 20 and even 30 point gains
one was called the miracle in milwaukee
the that investigator went to jail
ultimately for fabricating data
but the point is that jensen wrote an
article that said look
the opening sentence of his article is
classic the opening sentence is i may
not quote it exactly right but it's we
have tried compensatory education and it
has failed
and he showed that these games
were essentially nothing
you couldn't really document
empirically any gains at all from these
really earnest efforts
to increase iq
but he went a step further a fateful
step further
he said not only
have these efforts failed but because
they have had essentially no impact
we have to re-examine our assumption
that these differences are caused by
environmental things that we can address
with education we need to consider
a genetic influence whether there's a
genetic influence on this group
difference so you said that this is one
of the more controversial works i think
every most infamous paper in all of
psychology
i would go on to say
because in 1969
the genetic
data was very skimpy on this question
skimpy and controversial it's always
been controversial but it was even
skimpy and controversial
it's kind of a long story that i go into
a little bit in more detail in
the book neuroscience of intelligence
but
to say he was vilified is an
understatement i mean he couldn't talk
it at the american psychological
association uh without bomb threats
clearing the the lecture hall campus
security watched him
all the time they opened his mail
he had to retreat to a
different address
this was uh
one of the earliest kinds this was
before the internet and and kind of
internet
social media mobs
uh but it was that
intense
and i have written that overnight
after the publication of this article
all intelligence research became
radioactive
nobody wanted to talk about it
and then it it it didn't
it
nobody was doing more research
and then the bell curve came along
and
the jensen controversy was dying down i
have stories that jensen told me about
his interaction with the nixon white
house on this issue i mean it was this
was like a really big deal
you